so who ran a tighter ship I guess a
tighter TARDIS so I want to talk about
Doctor Who but I don't really want to
talk about what's going on with it
currently I'm prepared to just set that
aside I'm enjoying my rewatch of the
older stuff I'm about half I'm more than
halfway I'm getting to the tail end of
Davey's run and it's given me kind of a
new refreshed perspective on his run and
I thought well it's time to put the
question head to head who ran the show
better Russell T Davies or Steven Moffat
and I'm not just gonna do this you know
talking myself I'm bringing in a guest
and we're gonna talk it out so ladies
and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming crispy Pro crispy it's great
to talk to you thank you for
volunteering to do this no no thank you
very much very very much than you
counselor cakes this is this is going to
be an interesting discussion I think it
will be not just in case anybody tuning
into this isn't familiar with you just
like super quick you're sort of
relationship with Doctor Who version of
that story
well I only came in my first episode was
the lodger so I was I was very late in
the game but since then you know I've
gone back and I've watched heaps and
I've just fallen in love with the M
through through YouTube and everything
I've had a lot of cool experiences with
Doctor Who so I don't normally get
obsessed over things but Doctor Who is
not only one okay so even though you
start with the lodger I am assuming that
it's point you've at least seen all of
the modern era
Yes Doctor yes okay I'm still lacking
quite a lot of knowledge in the classic
area however they'll be very soon keep
change I mean like it's catching up on
classic it is a chore so yes so you were
brought on here because we're gonna have
ourselves a little conversation and a
little bit of a debate No
who the better showrunner was Russell T
Davies or Steven Moffat correct now the
reason you ended up here because I
actually peek behind the curtain for
folks I actually reached out to a couple
of people and just asked them if if you
were asked this what side would you go
on because I wanted to find someone who
in who normally like just their own
instinct would be to take the opposite
position that I'm gonna take on this
yeah as opposed to like it being Debate
team where I assign you serious I yeah
yeah yeah and first couple of people
went with the one that I'm gonna go with
you were the first to get to go the
other side yep so that does mean that
you're gonna be arguing in favor of
Moffat mm-hmm I'm gonna be arguing in
favor of Davies now the one thing that I
want to I want to be clear both to the
people watching and between the two of
us this is not about the quality of
their writing correct individual
episodes this is other qualities for
running the show overall because at
least for my park if we're debating
their merits as a writer Moffat wins
mm-hmm okay
interesting interesting yeah but as a
showrunner I think Davies did a little
bit better
mm-hmm well I wanna just stay before we
get into this and everyone watching this
I did not hate Russell T Davies as a
matter of fact I think he was an
excellent writer and did brilliant
things for the show so I don't want
people think oh my gosh he's a Russell T
Davies hater how could how could he go
you know I think I think for me I've
enjoyed both eras thoroughly just want
to say that before we get going oh no I
have as well and you know I I mean the
thing is Moffat wrote both what are
currently my favorite and most hated
atmospheres the one in there so like my
feelings about Bobby could be
complicating but he is he can be great
and I don't hate Moffat either but these
are stars still the positions that we're
gonna take you know I'm gonna give you
first crack if you were just to do your
overall pitch to me as to why you think
Moffat ran the show well what sort of
your bullet point
I loved his series ox however might like
thinking about I don't know series five
has a special place for me I thought it
was just an absolute fairytale and it
just kept you hooked and kept you going
in the whole story with Amelia and you
know they set up the fact that her
wedding was coming up and the crack in
the wall I thought that that was all
very well done and very well executed
and then like over time so I'm getting
mad messages right now how dare you it's
my it's my lawyers talking about Moffat
oh yeah and then like series six we had
36 was when I like first came into it
like the The Impossible Astronaut and
Dave the moment I told my favorite
episodes mainly because that was my
first ever series opener that I watched
like with everyone and I was very lucky
no one knew anything and then you know
when the doctor died that just shook me
and how that was a series arc at me
halts and then you know we had your car
and what she was and then I really I
really enjoyed the series arcs and what
he sets up throughout the series better
than Davies it even though Davies did a
great job with the you know the bad wolf
and and Rose coming back and the photo
sucks and you're like a more subtle up
it's that extent so yeah I just like to
see the dogs mainly here and and if
you're gonna if your main poll is gonna
be the series art that's probably a
decent argument honestly I've always
kind of felt that the series arts kind
of a weak point for the show no matter
who's been running it
they eat the way modern era doctor who
does series arts interesting which is to
just have something whether it be a word
in the case of Davies or anything just
keep repeating until we get to the
finale and then we explain what the heck
it was then yeah I hate well you I don't
hate that inherently I'm really sick of
it
so I actually don't take the series are
too much into account either way my my
thing with Davies and why he's actually
have gone up in my estimation as time
has gone on it's a couple of things
while I don't always love his focus on
the more melodramatic elements of Doctor
Who I like that his focus as a
showrunner has always been on the
emotional impact of the things you know
health he'll have you know the
occasional little bit of bendiness with
this narrative but by and large his
focus is on getting you emotionally
invested into the characters that's what
his interest is in that's what he really
wants the audience to do and the other
thing is I really feel that Davies
refined what he did with each series
that's not to say that every single
series was better than the latter
because I do think series one is better
than series two but I think you can
chalk up sort of not initially having
planned to have to regenerate that early
at for a little bit of wonky yeah but
even series two is you know it's sort of
taking the template of series one again
finding its footing with a new doctor
but then series three gets tighter
series four which is my favorite series
of the show overall gets tighter again
yeah if I were to compare that to Moffat
who I think his best series are series
five and series 10 and he really kind of
signed waved up and down all the way
between there I I have come to really
have an affinity for sort of the
reliability of of Davies
overall I feel like in some ways he he
couldn't hit the same highs as Moffat
did yeah that's like I was gonna say
yeah but he also didn't hit the same low
exactly and so it's a question of how
much of a roller coaster are you willing
later that's so true that's so well
that's a really good point light a
little bit Russell T really did focus a
lot on those relationships like you know
even with Martha and her family it like
Amy Pond we've we saw her mum and dad
one episode you know the strongest
relationship in Moffat Sarah was
probably Amy and Rory and they were
companions and like Clara Clara we saw
her parents nothing happened bill we saw
her like what what was it like who was
that woman you see I can remember who
that woman was that she lived with like
so it was just her room those
relationally yeah I know those
relationships were lacking in the Mafia
I will admit but I'd like as I said like
I feel like the Mafia just went crazy
and like he like as you said like he hit
the lowest of lows but he kept the
highest of the highs during the era and
I don't know I like I like his I like
his storytelling cuz it's a bit a bit
more riskier than Russell T and
sometimes it pays off sometimes it
doesn't
I think again I think it's one of those
things that like in theory I can get
behind it's just the results were very
iffy for me because I can appreciate
that Moffat took more chances yeah with
the way that he kind of shook things up
from series to series series 5 is very
much built off the template of the
Davies era in a lot of ways and then
series six and series 7 he he tried
something very different and then you
know even series 8 which was almost
entirely self-contained and then series
9 which was mostly two-parters you know
he kept trying to shake it up but there
are some times I'm like do you have a
plan or you're just doing something
different under a chance that maybe it
helps yes I'm not sure there was always
a plan or a reason for the shakeups and
maybe I'm maybe I'm just getting like
old and and like tired of me of being
jerked around but I there's something to
be said for reliability and actually I'm
it's now occurring to me it's not
dissimilar for one of the reasons that I
tend to like Marvel better than DC both
in terms of the movies and the comics
yeah which is that DC at its best is
usually far better than Marvel can be
but at least for my part I rarely find
that Marvel ever ticks me off as much as
DC's capable on me off that was one of
the single best coke
arsons I think I have ever heard that is
incredible ya know like that like Davies
I feel like he knew consistency you know
like the series one template it worked
it worked throughout his his era and
then you know like they messed it up a
little bit with the the David Tennant
specials but even then like like Davies
episodes have these certain flavors you
know I mean like it's got that it's got
that tank it's got that taste and it's a
good tape is great but firm offer you
know it can either it can either be the
most delicious thing ever we want to
vomit it back up and you can throw it to
Gallifrey and help it you know what I
mean well okay so if you're gonna go
food comparisons why do you say is what
well what I would say is that Davies was
the reliable higher end chain restaurant
like McDonald's but like Olive Garden
yeah you know it it's nice enough that
you've made it and and it's it's
consistent you know what you know
getting there mm-hmm
going into a Moffitt season or even in
you know an individual episode was like
going into a little out-of-the-way
restaurant no you hadn't heard of before
maybe you're gonna have an undiscovered
gem yeah best meal you've ever had maybe
you're gonna get food poisoning
mm-hmm yeah this is good I'm enjoying
these comparisons so III think with with
sort of that it it doesn't automatically
one doesn't make one automatically
better than the other but it is kind of
like a what-what gives you comfort is it
some reliability or yeah or the roller
coaster I think that that's just the
thing that's literally what it boils
down to like I I mean admittedly I did
grow up on the Mafia era so like I am a
little biased but I really I genuinely
enjoyed the roller coaster because like
you know the the series six open up
really high and then like the wedding of
River Song never paid off for me but
then like you know I even I I enjoyed
asylum of the Daleks as I was a bit of a
controversial one
I really like that one and I still have
a hard time figuring out why other
people don't but that that could be one
of the things that I can understand like
they marketed marketed the episode as I
was gonna have every Dalek in it and
then you know you see the the special
weapon style like for like two seconds
at the side of the screen like that
would have been if they even market that
at all and that was a sick Easter egg I
feel like wow everyone become oh my god
they had that in there you know see it
but the fact that works to my this is
where it works to my advantage that I
almost never pay attention to the
marketing and I come out you say that's
that's my problem I've had way too much
attention to the marketing yeah but yeah
I don't know I really I really genuinely
enjoy the roller coaster and why even
likes it like Judas said series Tim was
one of your favorite series of Muffet or
just like in jail ya know I think I
think that's probably my favorite Moffat
series and it's one of my favorite
series of the show you say like even
even down to the the series arc like
lost yes we were presented with the
vault and yet to like wait a while to
figure out what what this vault was but
then after that the series are changed
from you know what is this - can the
master Missy be good and that that was
brilliant
I loved how that played out and that let
last half of series 10 I feel like
that's a good way to do a series arc
which was which was one of the reasons I
liked series 10 better than a especially
in that element because yes it
introduced the same freakin thing but
time which is the vault what's in the
vault
but then they open the vault like
halfway through yeah you're like that so
now I'm surprised they didn't like
Capaldi was just sitting outside be like
Missy I need your help oh so that's
that's theirs in the vault yeah but it's
not like once you figure out who was
like okay so they did that now I don't
know where it's going yeah it's kind of
cool hmm agree so again it's really good
stuff and again part of me was surprised
that when I actually sat down and
thought okay if I'm gonna have this
conversation what side am I actually
gonna defend because like there's a lot
about Daviess era
that I take issue with the fact that I
raped Tennant as a middling doctor is
probably my most controversial Dorien
Wow
again not bad but he's been dropping
year-over-year you know as as time has
gone on and especially as I've taken in
more classic doctors I'm like doesn't
really work for me all that well he's
not the bottom David's the bottom but it
but you know so there's a lot in
Russell's era that I'm like this isn't
great but at the same time I look at
sort of what he did in in terms of what
his job was to get in there and guide
the ship and run the show and keep it on
course and to and to refine what it was
he did yeah year-over-year and to and to
have it and to have it build and to and
to learn from his mistakes which I think
in many ways Donna was a corrective to
Martha which is not to say Martha's a
bad character actually well you have a
lot but I think Davies realized boy
repeating that romance angle with the
companion again that really didn't work
two times over yeah let's do somebody
who does not have that dynamic with him
at all yeah it felt more like he was he
was trying to actually get better as
opposed to just let's just try something
different
mmm yeah no no I see what you mean like
that that's something that did annoy me
but in the in the day they say like what
did you think of the whole Rose and 10
dynamic they had from like the straight
after nine to ten I like it a little
better now having now gone back and
revisited series two because like sort
of in a way kind of expelling from my
mind what was the actual series you know
the the plant series arc the mystery box
of Torchwood oh yeah and actually
tracking it knowing where it's going and
tracking the series arc is being these
two are having so much fun that they're
not paying attention to how dire the
situations are being way too cavalier
about that and then having that payoff
in him losing her I have a much greater
appreciation for the build of that and I
say that then I did on first viewing
that said I'm not a huge fan of the
doctor having a romantic time the
companion like as a premise I don't like
that having said that that handled it
about as well as it has been handled or
yeah we could be handled no no I see
that I don't really think about that but
that like the you know that payoff at
the end with rose that that could be
argued that that's the stronger series
arc I like that I like that angle I
really do enjoy example and the ya know
I think was I did I did enjoy that
Martha was um you know like as you said
following in roses footsteps and I enjoy
the fact that it didn't pay off for her
like to be or like I like the fact that
you know the doctor didn't wasn't like
oh okay
you know roses go on Martha's got a
thing for me pretty much I enjoy but
like you know was annoying when she's
like you know that one of the last
things which is like you know I had a
roommate and you know never lived like
they never saw you know I don't know I
don't know what she says but I didn't
think that necessarily paid off for
Martha even though that is such a strong
series and such a strong three-part
finale but yeah you know say what you
gonna say well what I was gonna say was
funnily enough with like the with the
what happened with Rose in series two
Moffat almost did something similar with
Clarence in series 9 specifically
because he has Clara very much trying to
be like the doctor yeah and him warning
her along the way don't try and be me
yeah and that's ultimately what gets her
killed and face the Raven mm-hm
until hell-bent where he absolutely
destroys the orc that the entire for
this series but that's that's okay
that's okay look we don't have to talk
about helping
no no we don't end like I I do believe
and if people don't believe me when I
say this I don't blame you anyone who's
seen my hell ban rant nothing I don't
think I chose Davies strictly because I
hold that hard are helping I don't think
I did that but if if people believe that
I can't really fault no no look like the
I that's it's annoying that that episode
exists especially coming off the back of
Heaven Sent which is like I think that
it was like how would she like is it is
beautiful and like you know the way it's
filmed the way it's written and the
payoff at the end like that it was all
it was all very very well done and you
know like he was like morning Clara ie
was morning Clara and like they had the
entire series as you said to build off
the fact that you know it is dangerous
how close she became to being like the
doctor and how that's not a life that
anyone should live so I don't know if
he'll that didn't exist I feel like I'd
have a much better case but anyway yeah
but see the thing is funnily enough like
I haven't sent hell-bent those being to
continue is like that's basically my
feelings about Moffitt's run in a
nutshell that is that is my favorite new
who episode followed immediately by the
one I hate more than any other yes that
is a roller coaster all the whiplash of
that it's know at the same time that is
a that is a very high peak mmm well I
mean like I'm not I I feel like and and
this was actually kind of what I was
hoping for was that we wouldn't arrive
at a definitive answer but that we would
have like some of the the the strong
points of each of them as a showrunner
hmm and sort of get a chance to to lay
those out on on both sides that was like
ultimately that's kind of what I wanted
to happen out of this conversation and
and I feel
we're kind of getting there and I mean
like like you said when when we started
we actually both like both of these yeah
a hundred percent yeah hundred percent
but yeah it I think it is that it is the
the consistency versus versus the roller
coaster yeah definitely different well
what do you ask me like what like I
thought with some of the strongest
points of the the Moffatt era and I was
like well I really like the this series
ox that he had compared to Russell T
what what did what like what did you
like more about Russell's like was it
wasn't those relationships that were
formed or like what like was there more
to that I think the thing was as much as
I appreciate Moffitt's ability to do
some really cool narratives in terms of
the plot mechanics hmm ultimately what
sticks with me longer is those
connections it's those relationships
it's those dynamics and so I can't help
but favor a showrunner who put more
emphasis there because I think and again
this is not necessarily a fault I think
it's just a reality of of him is that
Moffat always had more of an interest
both in terms of individual episodes and
also his meta plots like the series six
does this hugely but with its with its
arc you know sort of really admittedly
very clever twisty plot mechanics yeah
and while that's very cool and I can
appreciate that it ultimately doesn't
stick with me the way that you know
Donna having to get her memory erased or
yeah you know Mickey making the choice
to stay behind to be with his gram of it
like that stuff sticks with me more than
the two then the twisty narratives do
the timey wimey yeah yeah I see that
well well let me ask you this would it
what did you think of the relationships
in the Moffatt era between doctor and
companion
you know you know 11 ami 11 Clara 12
Clara and 12 bill well worried if I kept
like compared to the Davy Zira well the
thing was I feel like the the only
relation I mean I don't think Moffat
really knew what to do with Clara as a
kite great I quite feel like out of
those out of those three Moffat era
companions she was my father weakest
initially and I feel like she was like
she finally had some kind of purpose in
like series 9 with her all like a series
arc that basically but like what like
one thing I like that
still annoys me to this day is the fact
that you know Clara just became a
teacher you know like I've tried
justifying it being like you know oh you
know she was she was taking care of kids
like she's obviously good with kids but
if they hadn't made one slight little
reference in the bells of st. John be
like oh you know I'm working I might
like my teaching practical that was a
good payoff but the fact that she was so
just there that the riders could
literally do anything with her annoyed
me initially but yeah yeah I'll solve it
let's I do think I need to get that
other way you go so like here's the
thing I feel like in many ways the a big
part of the reason I like Amy as much as
I do is because Rory is there I mean I
think if it had only been the doctor and
Amy that their relationship would not
have had the depth or or worked as well
for me and I did and again that might I
should be Moffat being self-aware as I I
have to have someone else in here
because otherwise the it's it's not
gonna quite work but like I feel the
doctors actual relationship with his
primary companion which is what Amy is
Rory is Amy's companion yeah is you know
that that actual relationship it's fun
and it's lighten it's playful but that's
the thing that's kind of what Moffat
does fun light playful relationships
which are very enjoy I mean that that's
the essence of work of River Song for
crying out loud
and while those are incredibly enjoyable
to watch when done well again I just I'm
not sure they have the same long-term
just sort of like it it sinks in and
stays like in your heart the way that
you know the the more connected
relationships can when when they work
well yeah interesting you know what do
you think of one of the most like
disconnected relationships being River
Song because that you know that's
Moffat's character and you know he did a
lot of things with her story but I feel
like that final little payoff at the end
of husbands of River Song I thought like
you know ever say like you know that
episode is like playful and light is art
Icarus especially well Matt Lucas then
like that that little payoff at the end
I thought was so unbelievably satisfying
and deep and I feel like that would that
was a great character payoff from offer
I'll give you that but like I I don't
know how much credit to give that them
often and how much of that is down to
the performers because that is basically
up until that payoff I feel like in many
ways River Song and you know from her
first introduction to sort of what
happens with her over time hmm is it's
Moffat trying to inject heartfelt
emotion into snarky flippant characters
and it's and as it goes as her
appearances progresses those are the
moments that kind of fall a little like
I make sure I buy that yeah okay okay I
can kind of see it but like I don't know
I feel like would what Davies do a
character such as River Song in his ear
because I feel like River Song is so
Moffat and no I genuinely I genuinely
enjoyed the idea of you know to two
lovers that
time out of sequence and then but I love
that idea I feel like I such a unique
and beautiful idea okay well I don't
know if Moffat would have done that in I
mean Davies would have done that in his
ear I don't think I I don't think he
would happen again that speaks to sort
of the the boldness of the ideas that
Moffat would bring to the table
and all the credit to him for that and
just like total side note have you read
the book the Time Traveler's Wife
because based off what you've just said
no I have never read that book don't
watch the movie read the book read the
book okay read the book I will do that
but ya know that that was that was
probably too too bold a narrative idea
because if Davies was bold at all he was
bold on the emotional front like I think
that what he did with Donna and then
later on with Wilf having Wilf be the
emotional core of the end of time I
write part 1 & 2 that was brilliant
yeah that was a very strong that was
that was an emotional you know bold idea
whereas again Moffat does the does the
timey wimey narrative bold ideas hmm
yeah yeah that that's a really good
point I thought I forgot that um Wilf
was there for that two-part finale that
was brilliant
so what what did you think of Donna's
introduction versus when she go cast in
series 4 because I wasn't here for the
time but like what was your initial
reaction with Donna and how she she
redeemed herself
well I mean like I I just at time of
recording fairly recently revisited the
runaway bride because I'm doing the
older doctor who reviews yeah you are
you're oh my god that hurt
damn that episode is painful why it's oh
and the thing is like I I'm because I'm
sort of doing a curated viewing of
Doctor Who with my partner Liz and I'm
probably gonna skip that one which is
gonna be rough because she's really
looking forward to Donna because we have
a mutual friend who like
basically is Donna her like she looks
like Donna and she has that attitude and
yeah so that's ridiculous really looking
forward to that I don't but and the
thing that I've seen people say and
obviously I was too disconnected from
you know from British pop culture at the
time this went on to appreciate this
what people have have said is that
basically Donna in the runaway bride was
just the stock Catherine Tate character
that she tended to do in her sketches
and her gear and all of that whereas
when she came on as the companion Davies
actually wrote a proper character for
hmm and I I'm prepared to buy that based
off what I what little I've seen of her
sketch comedy stuff it does tend to fall
into I'm funny because I'm loud yes
which is very much the angle that the
runaway bride is going for and and I
don't think it even works there but
arguably it works as a one-off but I'm
really glad that that Davies had the
presence of mind that when he's like
okay we're bringing her on we need to we
need to very carefully rework this yes I
feel like the same character but we got
out we got to do this better so actually
sort of injecting her with that sense of
melancholy and feeling like she missed
out when she told the doctor that she
wouldn't travel with him and like seeing
that way on her I think that did a lot
to sort of bring her down to earth a bit
so there she worked I think really well
I admit that that is a brilliant point
like her her payoff at the at the end of
series 4 so it's so heartbreaking you
know you wouldn't think that if you'd
only seen runaway bribery I know know
like it's great so like it's it it's
like Moffat does have his roller
coasters but I feel like Davies Davies
there's a few little little little bumps
in the track as well but he does redeem
himself in the
which is good yeah I mean like when I
say Davies is consistent that's not to
say that there would never Bad episodes
under oh yeah I know there Davies but
the thing that usually with Davies they
were more they were more hiccups and as
opposed to notable dips like I consider
most of series seven to be kind of a
kind of a low point yeah yeah I see what
you made what what what what did you
think of sorry I wasn't sure ingenuine
ly curious dinosaurs on a spaceship I
think it's about our episode than people
give a credit for honestly as do i I
write Jenny oh I feel like that's what
like it's it's not an episode it's gonna
stick with you forever and have like a
meaningful impact but I feel like it's a
great popcorn episode yeah but that was
sort of the I mean that Chibnall
actually wrote that one yes why this one
is interesting but that's that's the
thing about that about that episode is
like it's called dinosaurs on a
spaceship mmm the title alone kind of a
bit of a lark and yeah I'm so dumb I'm
like it's called dinosaurs on us what
did you think you were getting into yeah
and like I accept that there's some
Doctor Who fans where that's not the
kind of Doctor Who that they like yeah I
buy that but if you're willing to every
now and then take a lighter fluffier
episode then I don't see what's wrong
with that yeah interesting yeah I just
wanted to see your shorts on that one
interesting very very interesting so let
me so let me ask you because you bet
you've been asking me like a lot about
because I because I put the emphasis on
the relationships so like yeah with
Moffat what was the doctor companion
relationship that worked the best for
you that was the strongest for you
well I understand this is certain this
is such an interesting such an
interesting question because like I said
I grew up with the whole like Amy and
Rory thing and being obsessed with that
so that I thought it was so cool and
then Clara came in and you know I was
young at the time so I loved the mystery
of her but I never I never saw any like
sparks fly between eleven and Clara even
though I think there was a weird little
moment in hide where they like had some
weird chemistry and I was like that
doesn't work but for me like in
retrospect I feel like bill and 12 I
thought I thought bill was one of
Moffitt's best written companions just
like I in general and I liked I liked
the mentor dynamic that the doctor had
in the end and just like you know bill
bill was like like she was she was a
badass a bit sassy asked a lot of
questions but like I don't know so I
feel like those two just worked so well
together and I couldn't see Bill having
that whole you know I'm gonna be like
the doctor or I'm in love with the
doctor
I feel like Atlanta it was kind of it
was more along the lines of Donner
intent in any regards to prophets era
Donna has how I Donna and ten or seven
and eight is another good comparison I
think for them and and actually yeah I
really I really like them too because I
like she's impressive but I get the
sense that she doesn't idolize him the
way so many a modern know our companions
do she's like oh there's this there's
this older guy who's done and seen a lot
I have a chance to see some stuff with
him cool I'll do that yeah
and she actually seems genuinely
interested about like learning more
about like what's out they'll I remember
in smile she like so I pull the doctor
aside for a thing like you know thank
you this is like the our camera which is
like this is the best like you got what
do you say
I don't like field trip ever
like she's Jenny like she's genuinely
having like a great great time you know
seeing the universe seeing what's out
there cuz you know she was she was well
I like the fact that she wasn't actually
at university and she was just in the
kitchen she would go to lectures just to
learn things yeah I feel like she was
such a cool character it's a shame she
only got one season but at the same time
I'm glad that that was her season you
know what's another thing that just
occurred to me and as you said that that
I hadn't realized before and it's
probably a big part of why I like
Capaldi and Bill a lot he wasn't trying
to impress her
no because the know the doctor has done
that all he definitely did it with Rose
mm-hmm in a kind of a jerk way he did it
with Martha that backhanded way yeah and
I think you know 11 definitely was
trying to impress Amy I love that that
Capaldi was at no point trying to
impress her no he uh you didn't really
want a companion at the start yeah so
like I don't I feel like that was just
like two mates just seeing the universe
seeing what's out there and I like that
I feel like I feel like that was Moffat
being like okay I await a bit too
ambitious with Clara there let's just
bring it back to reality for a second so
yeah I do I really do enjoy series 10
and Bill and that whole arc and like
Missy series 10 is great I'm having a
lot of appreciation from series 10 in
this this conversation right now
i I do likes it like it was weird
because I don't I don't see it argued as
much anymore so I do wonder if it's one
of those things that have people have
gotten a little more distance from it
they backed off from it but I remember
at the time people like every series
he's done has gotten worse I'm like
really cuz tennis was really good yeah
yeah no definitely definitely mmm but
I'm trying I'm trying if there was
anything else I wanted to I wanted to
hit cuz like here's that here's another
thing that just occurred to me is like
trying to think of like the handling of
villains under each of them oh so like
I think Moffat tried a bit more of
trying to create new villains because
obviously I mean they premiered they
debuted during Davies era but there's
the there's the weeping angels there's
the silence yeah there's Missy I think I
for my money Missy is Davies biggest hit
when it comes to villains Jimmy you mean
doing Davey's Moffitt's biggest hit and
what and with Davey's I feel like I
think overall I would still rate Davies
a little bit better because I I look at
things like the Dalek episodes under
Davies and I think oh yeah the Daleks
just felt way more dangerous in the
Davies yeah they agree became
increasingly trivialized as Moffat Sarah
went on and I thought the the that
initial return of Davros was chilling
and yeah I I think when it came to and
and what I say those I mean most of the
recurring cuz when you get into one off
that can be more dependent on the
individual writer which may or may not
I'm trying to like think of like I know
like an original monster from Davies
that sticks out to me and I I'm actually
struggling here because I can't really
think of well I mean there's the Slovene
which I think might be the only ones
that were Kurd who weren't yeah Junaid
and classic you went one off but I mean
I like midnight that was cool
well I love men if you're talking truly
really once but yeah the midnight entity
is freakin terrifying but even the
Slovene I would still kind of point to a
sort of showing one of Davey's as
strengths because while this Levine are
not great I think boomtown especially in
the depiction of a Slovene character
works way better than
their original two-parter oh yeah
because yeah coming off a good he seemed
to have learned like okay the farting
was too much like the whole baby face
they baby baby face alien thing didn't
really work we're gonna show that as
little as possible we'll do one fart
reminder but other than that let's let's
let's refine this idea and make it work
better
well that's interesting like cuz I feel
like you know just from a purely
behind-the-scenes standpoint that would
have had to have filmed like boomtown
and the the you know the original
Slovene two-parter before that even went
to air so I'm like I'm wondering if it
was like through his writing or if
someone thought about me like you know
maybe have less fight jokes in boomtown
because like I like people I know people
I don't people that are really fans of
boomtown but I I I love it I think it's
one of my favorite episodes of series
one because it is a bit and slowed down
and you're like you really feel the
stakes of like the you know that the
debate between should the doctor you
know let this creature go or should like
you know or whatever it was like but
yeah I don't I don't know from from
behind the scenes standpoint I don't
know if that was him learning or if that
just happened to be the case well it's
it's it's hard to be certain one way or
the other if I were to guess I would say
most likely because I'm pretty sure they
do I mean they shoot these in in blocks
but I'm pretty sure that the fan block
for the two-parter happened first oh
yeah yeah I know wood and mice my
personal suspicion would be that he he
looked at the finished product of that
or you know even though the rough cut
the Edit and went oh okay me maybe tone
it down a little when we do the next one
yeah yeah yeah yeah be another sorts
living one of his one of my one of his
only like big creations that I can think
of but then like with Moffat as you
saying like he's got he's got so many
like the silence they freaked me out as
a kid and I like you know I I'm at
college now
and you know there there are a few who
viens but you know here I can introduce
it to a lot of people and I normally
show them my personal favor The
Impossible Astronaut Dave the moon
they're like oh my gosh that is that is
terrifying that is chilly I'm like you
know yeah people you know people hiding
behind the sofa is you know what what
Doctor Who is about and so I don't know
in a lot of and a lot of regards I feel
like Moffat scared me more than Davies
if you go to Doctor Who for scares yes
he's what he is mad at them because I
think I mean we said we weren't going to
talk about individual episodes so much
but just like for Harrison I think that
midnight is probably the only Davies on
episode that is that one's that one's
hard to watch without you know like
hiding alone is creepy I think it's one
of the best things you wrote and it is
very creepy and unsettling and kind of
terrifying but it's really just the one
whereas whereas Moffat the empty child
is scary Oh weeping angels are scary the
silent listen Mary so ya know that
there's a lot there's a lot be yeah we
were saying individual episodes but I
feel like in terms of scare factor
Morphet probably does take back yeah
yeah and I mean I think that's that's
what we keep coming back to is which one
ultimately is better depends on what you
as a viewer yeah this it's literally all
downs the individual is what you it's
what sticks with you the most after you
see Doctor Who you know it is it is it
the you know the really cool twisty
narratives is it being scared is it
feeling more emotionally invested in the
characters and different eras will give
you different things which I I actually
like overall yeah I like that with the
change in showrunner can bring a shift
in emphasis so that it's not just being
the same thing until it gets run into
yeah
as we were saying it does come down to
the individual like I know that from
what I've got you you love the
relationships and the payoff and like
the heartbreak and everything and I love
that
as well but I also love Muffet messing
with time and unlimited eyes and being
scared so I like I said it all does come
down to individual preference so like
doctor who's just a great show in
general there's always something
something someone's gonna like and
something I someone's really not gonna
like yeah and honestly I think I think
that's probably a good note to wrap up
on gonna keep going we're just gonna
keep yeah the same thing yeah so again
thank you so much for doing this
No thank you so much for having me if
people who don't already know who you
are like have you seen you on here where
can they find you uh you can find me on
YouTube crispy Pro I do just a lot of
similar things to the legend council of
geeks here but you know like I don't
know it's all it's all it's just a lot
of fun it's just a lot of fun there's a
lot of good who tubers out there council
of geeks is one of them and I want it to
be on here today so thank you well thank
you and yeah this was this was a good
time thanks so much for being here
no thank you thank you very much thank
you all for watching thanks again to
crispy fur you know participating in
this thing we kept things pretty civil
which is what I love about the who
tubers that I know like we don't always
agree but like we can talk this is fun
let's chat it out so thanks so much for
watching and there's a whole bunch of
stuff down the description you know all
this stuff patreon that's kind of the
big one but you know there's merch p.o
box social media links link to my book
yeah it's all down there so give them a
look click on stuff it'll take you
places but also you don't really have to
I'd appreciate it but you know what at
the end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meeting so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]